uh
[Music]
[Music]
in recent years
over 700 000
people in the donbass have taken russian
passports most of them by the way have
kept ukrainian passports so it wasn't
either or they were hedging their bets
because you ukraine had stopped services
a lot of services payments of welfare
benefits and so on
[Music]
[Music]
the dawn pass there was an insurgency
and instead of talking to the people in
the donbass
the uk government launched violent
attack including destruction of donetsk
airport which had been built and
modernized for the 2012 european
football championship
and of course
this is important to discuss that moscow
and russia was very hesitant to support
this movement the insurgency or
separatism in the donetsk and
lugansk regions
[Music]
it's not as if uh this is coming out of
nowhere the west has had some 30 years
to come to terms with 20 years of putin
and it has failed utterly to engage as
putin said you didn't listen to us then
and now he's no doubt saying it listen
to us now